you know during the during the pandemic  and everything going on a lot of people  have been cooped up restaurants were  closed some restaurants have food trucks  in a different in a  addition to brick and mortar some don't  we really wanted to help the small  businesses and the small local  businesses which our food trucks are a  part of that  just to keep going whatever we can keep  going during this difficult  time  i love seeing kids run up to the truck  like they're so happy to see us  this is gonna sound weird but i think  the only time we ever disappoint anyone  being here is if we run out  we're in our food truck making donuts  for smiles  and uh you get that in families and  communities  [Music]  you